-Salut !
Il y a quelques semaines,
le premier décembre pour être très précis,
j'ai fait une vidéo avec un mec qui s'appelle Youtunes.
Et on avait eu comme délire
de faire une chanson qui vous mentalise.
Mais j'ai une petite frustration en fait,
je n'ai jamais mentalisé ce mec.
Sauf qu'il avait besoin d'être hébergé
ce soir sur Paris...
Donc il stresse,
il est pas loin de moi,
mais je vais mentaliser Youtunes...
Ce soir !
-Je suis un peu stressé !
[respiration forte]
-Ce qui est bien c'est que ça ne se voit pas...!
Alors, j'ai eu l'idée il y a quelques secondes, je ne sais même pas si ça va fonctionner ou pas, c'est un test, c'est comme d'hab en fait !
Générique !
[Générique]
-Est-ce que tu peux confirmer que
tu ne sais pas ce qu'on va faire ?
Et tu sais pourquoi ?
Parce que même moi je ne suis pas encore
convaincu de savoir ce qu'on va faire.
-Mais je crois
que oui c'est ça l'histoire...
Je viens d'arriver en fait chez Fabien,
faut le savoir.
-Exactement.
-Je suis arrivé, il y a dix minutes.
-Bon, j'ai préparé des petits papiers,ça ne ressemble à rien, mais en fait mon idée ça va être de construire un piano avec ça.
Dans un premier temps, je vais avoir besoin que tu... que tu choisisses le nom d'une chanson.
Mais pas n'importe comment !
Le nom de la chanson que tu vas choisir il faut que ce soit un mot de 5 lettres.
Ok ?
Qui existe ou qui n'existe pas.
-Je prends mon temps parce que j'essaye de trouver un truc qui ne soit pas trop commun quand meme...
J'ai mon mot.
-Il fait cinq lettres ?
-Il fait cinq lettres.
-C'est un mot qui existe ?
-C'est un mot qui existe.
-Je vais écrire quelques petites choses derrières ces bouts de papier.
Yes !
-Et la mentalisation va commencer.
Néanmoins, il faut que vous le sachiez : Je fais des petits cuts là, et je vais en faire un là tout de suite parce qu'on a commandé...
-Une pizza !
-Une pizza qui est en train d'arriver.
-Elle est comme çà...
-...et du coup, je n'ai pas envie qu'on soit coupé en plein élan donc je vais juste aller réceptionner la pizza avant.
-En fait Fabien, il est parti chercher la pizza et il m'a laissé tout seul avec la caméra donc voilà... je.... je fais des choses qui ne servent à rien.
[grognement de petit chien]
Là il y a son chat qui vient de
se battre avec le chien...!
Je coupe !
Au revoir...
-Bon, on a été chercher la pizza, ça c'est bon.
[You - Soupir de contentement]
Tu peux témoigner, je ne t'ai pas posé
de question sur ton mot pour le moment.
-Absolument pas.
-Alors maintenant je vais t'en poser, maintenant que ça re-filme, ça re-filme bien ? ... oui !
Je sais que ce n'est pas un mot classique.
-Ok. Je vais écrire pleins de choses, un peu partout et après on en parle.
Tu peux penser à la première lettre
quand même ?
-Ouais.
-C'est important...
-J'y pense, j'y pense...
-C'est souvent les consonnes les premières lettres, hein ?
[You - Soupir amusé]
-Il est très lisible, c'est très facile !
-C'est faux !
C'est peut-être un piège.
-C'était une consonne.
C'est une consonne en fait.
C'est une affirmation de ma part, hein ?
-D'accord, ok.
-Euh... Peut-être tu as pris un truc
qui est au milieu de l'alphabet ou la fin...
Peut-être tu as pris un N ou un M, quoi, tu vois...Peut-être tu as pris un T... ou un P...
-Mais peut-être que je joue très bien mon jeu et que je suis un très bon acteur.
-C'est ça !
-Aussi...
-Je ne sais pas quoi écrire...
Il y a des trucs je sais écrire,
des trucs je ne sais pas quoi écrire.
[Musique]
-Il ne savait même pas ce qu'il allait faire juste avant de tourner, mais c'est ça qui est ouf !
-C'est pour ça, je pense que la préparation à l'air un petit peu laborieuse, et là je vais constituer maintenant avec tous ces papiers que j'ai rempli une sorte de piano.
-Alors, d'ailleurs, petit conseil musical: si vous commencez dans la musique et que vous cherchez un piano...
[Apparté à Fabien]
Je ne suis pas du tout sûr de celle-là...
-Vas-y...
-C'est pas très cher...et vous pouvez vous entraîner.
Nan, faudra cut !
Faudra cut vraiment !
-Non ! Non, non...
-Malaise TV ! Malaise TV !
-Malaise TV là !
Non, je ne suis pas bien !
-Ça met en valeur certaines
de mes vannes du coup.
[rire]
Voilà, ça c'est un piano.
On va jouer, nous, avec les blanches.
La mentalisation, elle commence
à partir de maintenant.
Sauf si elle a commencé à partir
du début de cette vidéo.
Voici ce qui va se passer: je vais te montrer deux notes blanches, et tu vas me dire laquelle on supprime.
-Oui
-Tu me dis : "Tiens..." on supprime laquelle ?
Parmi ces deux...
-Celle-ci !
-Celle-ci ?
-Ouais...
Donc c'est celle sur laquelle j'avais écrit "Poire".
Je regarde un peu comment tu réagis.
au P, au O, au I, au R, au E ce genre de choses...
Et je déchire, puisqu'on ne garde
plus ça.
-D'accord.
-Donc tu m'en fais voir deux
toi également.
-Ces deux là, d'accord.
Vas-y, fais voir.
Euh, oui, je supprime celle-ci.
Pomme !
Je supprime "Pomme".
-D'accord.
-Sur celle-ci, il est écrit "Pomme".
Comme j'écris très légèrement au crayon de papier, parce que je ne veux pas qu'il voit par transparence.
Alors je ne sais pas si vous voyez bien
ce qu'il y a de marqué à chaque fois.
La dernière !
Tu peux changer...
Si tu le souhaites.
-Hum... c'est comme dans
A prendre ou à laisser du coup.
-Exactement.
-Ok.
T'es un mec de convictions,
et...
Pêche !
Tu as vu, j'avais beaucoup d'inspiration... au niveau des fruits !
- Ouais... Au niveau des fruits c'était... c'était présent.
-Euh... Celui là.
Celui qui est en face de moi.
Un fauteuil !
-Oh, un fauteuil !?
-Ça, c'était sur la fin,
je ne savais plus quoi écrire.
Euh... ces deux là, tiens,
les extrêmes.
-Je vais prendre l'extrême gauche.
-Ah, mais du coup c'est mon extême droite,
à moi.
Bravo...
Chaise !
-Peut-être ces deux là, là...
-Ok.
Allez, je supprime, celle... extrême gauche mais la mienne du coup ce coup-ci.
-Ouais.
-Euh... Youtunes !
-Oh ! Un mot en 5 lettres !
-Et tu ne t'es pas supprimé toi.
Alors écoute, maintenant, il y a un choix.
On joue toujours avec ce piano, il reste toutes les noires et il reste une blanche.
Est-ce que tu veux qu'on commence
par retourner la blanche, ou est-ce que tu veux qu'on commence par retourner les cinq noires ?
-Woha... on va dire les 5 noires,
allez...
-Les 5 noires.
-Ouais.
-Ok.
J'ai besoin, pour la première fois, que tu dises quel mot tu avais en tête.
-Pyrex.
[Fab] Le truc en pyrex...
-Ça s'écrit en 5 lettres.
Je t'ai dit...
peut-être que la mentalisation avait commencé avant.
Peut-être...
Parce que moi, derrière cette noire là
il y a un P je vous ferai voir après.
Il y a un Y.
Il y a un R.
Il y a un E.
Et il y a un X.
-Bon...
-Après, peut-être que tu aurais préféré qu'on retourne la blanche ?
La blanche c'est, malgré les choix que tu as fait et les choix que j'ai fait, c'est la seule qui est resté.
Il y avait Pomme, Poire, Chaise,
Fauteuil, etc.
Et derrière la seule blanche qui restait...
-Tu te fous de ma gueule ?
pour confirmer j'avais juste écrit: "Pyrex".
Pyrex comme ça,
Pyrex comme ça, Pyrex comme ça...
Et ouais mon gars :
P - Y - R - E - X
PYREX !
-Bon du coup, euh....
J'appelle juste un taxi, vite fait parce que je vais rentrer à Grenoble...
[rire]
...au final.
Non, là c'est ouf !
C'est OUF !!!
Non mais...
Tu viens de me cramer, en fait,
le peu de neurones.
[Fab - Chantant] Qu'on me donne un P
Qu'on me donne un Y
Qu'on me donne un R
Qu'on me donne un E
Qu'on me donne un X !!!
[Fab] PYREX !
-Brrrouaaa !
C'est très énervant en fait !
C'est très énervant !
-C'était chaud, hein ! Je ne pensais pas réussir aussi bien,
parce que le challenge était d'anticiper le mot avant même de commencer à écrire en te faisant croire que je ne l'avais pas encore pécho.
-Mais...
-Et après, de faire les bons choix,
pour avoir ça au final.
-Ça m'énerve !!!
-Merci mec !
Alors si jamais vous ne connaissez pas la chaîne de Youtunes il remixe des voix de youtubeurs
connus ou plus ou moins connus.
Il fait aussi des parodies de clips qui sont énormes au niveau du montage de l'écriture, de tout !
Je surkiffe cette chaîne.
Je ne suis pas le seul, je sais que Squeezie surkiffe ta chaîne, Amixem, Pierre Croce...
Tout le monde !
Ça ne parle que de toi dans le Youtube Game !
-Alléluia !
Donc faites en sorte qu'il passe la barre des 20 abonnés.
Vous pouvez vous abonner à Youtunes en cliquant sûrement par ici, à moi aussi, si la vidéo vous a plu,
ben vous vous abonnez, vous likez...
Vous pouvez nous lâcher un petit com ça fait du plaisir !
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H !
Ciao !
-Ça fait du plaisir.
[Musique]